once every four years the quiet german
town of hess ish olden door becomes the
temporary heart of the volkswagen world
in june over 45,000 VW fans again
descended on the place for the 2017
edition of the international vintage
Volkswagens show hosted by its
initiators Christian Goodman and his
father 12 God as 12 God explains it all
started in 1994 with a crazy idea of his
son and his friend Bjorn they invited
Volkswagen to Hesse shoulder door Paul
God suggested they get better organized
but eventually got involved himself it
was such a hit that many people said
they'd like to come again so they held
the next show two years later the first
show had 68 cars
the second 280 and now it's got over 900
for a few days hence each old indoors
picturesque old town is clogged with
classic pre-1968 VW's with streets
devoted to specific models from the
beetle to the VW Transporter and Karmann
Ghia
while God is proud to report that they
have cars from 28 nations and visitors
from 49 countries this year was a record
with four cars setting out for Hesse
sholden d'Or from Malaysia three months
beforehand that shows just how big the
VW family is at the world's largest
vintage VW meet the people's car lives
up to its name
bringing fans together from all over the
world a Scottish bagpipes player
welcomes the Malaysian marathon drivers
about 22,000 plus kilometer
to be here it was simply a wonderful
journey if anyone who drives an
air-cooled and say they didn't have a
breakdown
yes there is they'll always be really
fix it along the way we still reach all
the destination on time I never miss a
shadow yeah
we're the Malaysian Adventures a sense
of honor requires them to drive their VW
all the way back to a no doubt make lots
of more friends along the way
it's a big family of Volkswagen when I
travel with them this I actually
experience how they come out bring
people together the car maker itself has
set up a special exhibition to provide
an in-depth look at the company's long
history parked next to the world's
oldest surviving beetle our unique
reproductions of long-lost prototypes
on-delay is horny technical director of
VW's classic car collection back at
headquarters in Wolfsburg he gives us
the lowdown these are four magnificent
vehicles for the enthusiasts here that
represent the birth of the beetle
starting with a 1936 of e3 a prototype
followed a year later by the v30 with
lots of modifications also on show the
world's oldest beetle the 3803 it was
the third car to be built in 1938 and
the first to go into post-war production
it was known as the CCG be like the VW
Beetle conceived and designed in the
1930s over 20 1.5 million had come off
the production line by the time it was
phased out in 2003 it is without a doubt
the preeminent car of the 20th century
that doesn't know anyone who doesn't
have some relative who's driven of oh
swag and he says Volkswagen is a link
between people there are no complexes
everyone helps everyone else on delay as
Hornitos
how the entire town gears up for the
show every four years the shop windows
are all decorated with Volkswagen
paraphernalia while the streets are car
themed
and as everybody knows how Volkswagen
runs forever
[Music]
and on a rally through local Hills the
vintage VW's encounter a rare amphibious
relative VW's type 166 has no need of a
ferry to cross the river
this driver explains it's part beetle
part Porsche it does up to 73 km/h it
was built from 1941 to 1943 and is
awesome to drive on the water
the schwimmwagen does an impressive 10
kilometres per hour that many of the
14,000 built have survived
it's something completely new for the
Malaysian VW fans campgrounds have been
laid out for the fans all around has
this olden Dorf and the multinational
atmosphere is very relaxed the
International vintage show is like a
Woodstock of VW devotees this couple
from Germany might not understand what
everyone's saying but they understand
what they mean what I really like about
folks is the community you can go around
talk about folks is also cool and this
visitor from Belgium finds friends of
every nationality yeah it's a long trip
but I think it's worth it it's a really
nice place to be and it's a good
atmosphere and everybody's happy I think
it's perfect the way it is it's a
Volkswagen festival and it's worldwide
well now Schmidt confirms that what
they've seen so far tops everything the
organization is wonderful
thanks to the 30 volunteers who've made
the event another resounding success